[Musique]
avec nous maintenant françois lenglet
éditorialiste économique à rtl et tf1 en
france mon soir monsieur l'anglais
bonsoir sacré quand même tout un émoi
cette nouvelle en france d'abord parlez
nous un peu de l'importance de cette
entreprise carrefour dans l'économie
dans l'histoire commerciale de france
oui vous êtes fous c'est exactement la
bonne question carrefour c'est la france
si vous voulez symbole de cette france
des trente glorieuses et d'une certaine
réussite française c'est-à-dire la
réussite dans les services cette
entreprise a écouté a été créée dans les
années 60 le premier hypermarché qu'elle
a ouvert c'était dans la banlieue
parisienne en 63 à sainte geneviève des
bois
et puis a suivi toute une série de
décennie où l'entreprise n'a fait que
racheter ses concurrents se développer à
l'étranger pour frôler la place de
numéro un mondial au début des années
2000 donc c'est assez emblématique
aujourd'hui l'entreprise n'est plus du
tout dans la même dans la même vitalité
ou dans la même forme même si justement
elle est en train de se transformer et
ça crée donc un choc de 2,2 de réaliser
que carrefour qui était leur acheteur
est devenu potentiellement le racheter
et donc est ce que c'est pour cela c'est
ce chapka qui amène le ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire à dire je ne suis pas favorable à
cette transaction
bien sûr il ya cet élément là qui est
déterminant il y en a un autre je dirais
qui est structurelle en france et que de
toute façon à partir du moment où une
entreprise étrangère s'intéresse à un
fleuron français il ya toujours une
réaction de méfiance
et puis il ya un troisième argument qui
étiez là de l'ordre conjoncturel si vous
voulez on s'est rendu compte pendant le
confinement à l'occasion de l'épidémie
du que vivent 19 que l'approvisionnement
même en produits
courant pouvait représenter quelque
chose de stratégique pour le pays et le
peut en fait la france a fait
l'expérience de sa dépendance en matière
pharmaceutique mais dans bien des
domaines et du coup elle est beaucoup
plus sensible que d'habitude encore et
au fait que ces entreprises puissent
être achetées par du capital qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient originaires hors de
france donc
carrefour est devenu une entreprise
stratégique ça ça semble paradoxal parce
que au fond se dit dans une économie
mondialisée où les circuits
d'approvisionnement sont multiples
autant je n'ai pas pour la pharmacie les
vaccins les masques on peut le penser
autant pour le fromage au lait yaourt ça
se discute
oui mais c'est vrai qu'on est dans un
climat politique qui légitime ce
discours là et qui fait que finalement
le pays se sent un petit peu inquiet et
qu' ils redoutent de perdre le contrôle
de ses centres de décision économique
dates s'ajoutent ça c'est un élément
purement factuel que carrefour est le
premier employeur du pays en dehors de
l'administration qui comme vous le savez
en france est assez important est ce à
dire que cette transaction si le
gouvernement français ne l'approuvent
pas s'il y a bien sûr une offre formelle
la de costard est ce à dire que cette
transaction ne vivra pas je pense
qu'elle ne pourra pas se faire sans
l'approbation des autorités politiques
des autorités d'une vision du ministère
l'économie alors la réaction de bruno le
maire tout à l'heure était assez
vigoureuse
est ce que c'est une position de
négociation de façon à obtenir des
garanties à la fois sur le maintien des
centres de décision en france sur le
maintien de l'emploi en france
ou bien est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui à moyen terme pourrait empêcher que
la transaction ne se conclue je ne
saurais vous le dire à l'heure actuelle
il est certain que ça fait monter la
barre un petit peu plus haut et que de
toute façon dans une négociation comme
celle ci vous avez l'acheteur le vendeur
et le gouvernement
c'est inévitable en france en tout cas
certainement en france une profession
merci beaucoup françois lenglet merci à
vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d